David it's great to see you at collects
ammonia here today how you been joining
it so far this has been fantastic you
guys have been great warm it's actually
warm today I like to think I brought
some of the sunshine but I'm glad really
glad glad to be here you guys have been
fantastic
now of course arrows such a popular show
so much excitement around as well on a
season finales just happened we've seen
so many things as well your wife is just
coming back separated from it she's
pregnant what did you make of that
there'll be a little Diggler coming very
very soon it's great you know every time
we read the script me and Steve are just
talking about this like our jaws drop
because we're fans right we watched the
show and we're we're like wow how did he
do this how did they do that and so when
I found out that I was gonna have a
child and found out and that's the same
episode that Oliver has a child from the
past and that will both be father's in
season 3 it's just been it's just been
great I mean they have so much plan for
season 3 you guys have a lot to look
forward to what are you looking forward
to in particular about taking your
character forward for season 3 Suicide
Squad
I mean obviously it's you know that the
relationship between Oliver and Diggle
will is is the bedrock
one of the major most important elements
of the show I think and that will still
be there both of these men are damaged
both these men are challenged in terms
of developing good relationships but the
Suicide Squad has really taken off I
mean it's it has a life of his own the
relation between Deadshot and Diggle has
just been something that's been
unexpected so there'll be more
development with with the Suicide Squad
that I'm really looking forward to he
could give Diggle any advice for future
seasons what would it be don't trust - I
know III think just continue on the
right thing you know I really admire
John Diggle you know John diggle's for
me is just somebody I kind of look up to
and respect them his sense of loyalty
and honor is
off the charts
I think I think he learned something
this season that you know I think he's
he has been maybe a little too
idealistic and in that ideal of idealism
he's been a little rigid and I think
he's learned a little bit about himself
and maybe bending a little bit so I
think you know Stephen and I think
Oliver Queen has kind of gone and to
going from the vigilante to the hero and
I think for Diggle he's gone I think
he's become a little more accessible in
that he he understands that is not black
and white
yeah it's more grapes in the middle and
so there's I think he's on the right
path he would you like to spend more
screen time with on the show and he
would you'd like to face off with as
well and why well I think that you know
I would love to have gotten a whole of a
China white again I think there's a
Diggle China white fight someplace in
the future coming up we had two fights
now there was a fight season one there's
a fight season two and you know she won
one maybe I won the other the
championship rounds are coming so China
white I want to get a hold of her again
yeah John Barrowman is becoming a season
regular going forward what do you think
about that and what you think it's gonna
bring to the show
what doesn't John Barrowman bring to the
show you kidding me John John is he he
steals every scene he's in John Barrow
he's a thief Big John Barrowman no I
can't wait for him to come I think he's
just gonna bring another he you know he
just takes every scene to another level
I think he's gonna bring some
interesting dynamic what's gonna happen
between his character and Thea I think's
gonna be very important Thea is gonna
have a great season next year because
she becomes dark so no I'm looking
forward to everything that John Barry's
not is that not only as an actor but
what the writers giftable of course
you've got the flash as well and we know
that Stephen amell's going to be in that
what do you think of the flash being a
new show and would you like to be part
of that world well I think you'll see
some crossover I think some of the right
I think the writers and the executives
in general want flash to kind of exist
on his own I can't really speak for them
but I think that's kind of the idea and
so maybe there'll be some crossover but
maybe not as much as you might think but
everyone's looking forward to flash I
mean a flash takes off and you have two
great successful superhero Frank
DC's franchises on television I mean
that's just great for TV and you know
Grant who doesn't love Grant Gustin he's
so freaking cute right so know
everyone's really looking forward to the
flash and I can't wait as a fan DC so
you busy at the moment with the flash
arrow of course you've also got Justice
League movie coming up a lot of people
would like to see Stephen Amell in that
as the do you like your characters begin
of course everyone would be I would love
to be part of justice I mean this is
just uncharted territory for us had to
have to have you know what happened in
the feature world in terms of Superman
and now Batman versus Superman coming
out and hopefully a Justice League movie
and what's happening with arrow and and
the flash
it's just I'm thanking my lucky stars
knocking on wood Diggle can't die
finally and what do you think of Ben
Affleck as the new Batman we've just
recently seen him revealed in his suit
and his Batmobile as well what do you
think it's gonna bring to roll and what
do you think that movies gonna be like
Batman vs Superman we're getting loads
of new characters not universe as well
yeah I think that you know I think that
was an incredibly good casting choice
and I think a lot of people kind of have
problems initially with it for whatever
reason I think busy and terrific actor
that he's gonna bring a lot of things to
the Caped Crusader that we haven't seen
and you know I can't wait to see how
exactly he's gonna fight Superman
you know the ingenious ways that he
comes up to knock Superman across the
room I can't wait for that I think it's
gonna be better than what anyone expects
you know DC's really taking their time
to do things but I think they're getting
it right
watch out marvel if you could bring any
other character into the world of arrow
who would you like to see well hopefully
Harley Quinn hopefully we see more
probably you know and hopefully on our
show on arrow I will love I don't know
what's going to happen I really
I will love to see Bruce Wayne not so
much Batman I want to see Bruce Wayne in
love you speaking to thanks so much your
time David thanks I see you Muslim
you